I get asked frequently why I chose to
become a math teacher one day I asked my
you 10 class why so many people were
curious about this decision and they
explained it like this sir so many
people dislike maths that's why I wonder
why anyone would choose a profession
where you not only have to do maths
every day but also have to try and teach
maths or students who dislike it so let
me try to explain the reasons why I
became a math teacher and why maybe even
you should consider doing the same
everyone wants to find a career that's
rewarding and worthwhile we want to be
able to get up in the morning and feel
motivated to go to work not just for
days weeks and months but for years and
decades
I wonder what criteria you have in your
mind for how you'll choose your career
money status and the author Daniel pink
talks about how science and research
have identified three main factors that
seem critical to long-term motivation
and those three factors are autonomy
mastery and purpose autonomy is the
desire to direct our own lives mastery
is the urge to get better and better at
something that matters and purpose is
the yearning to do what we do in the
service of something larger than
ourselves autonomy mastery and purpose
what I love about teaching maths is that
it's got all three in spades autonomy
there's so much flexibility in how you
explain concepts and skills what
activities you do with your classes and
how you help people learn you can throw
tennis balls in the air to demonstrate
projectile motion pour water into giant
martini glasses to explain rates of
change whether that measure the heights
of trees to demonstrate trigonometry or
fold and cut paper to illustrate
symmetry you can make your explanation
into a story and take your students on a
journey of understanding you can open
their eyes to the beauty of what they're
learning in any way you like and that's
not even mentioning the kind of autonomy
you get from teaching in general
whatever your particular kinds of
interests and skills you can find or
make an avenue for it at school through
extracurricular groups I have a web and
graphic design background so one of the
earliest projects I took on was to
redesign my school's intranet from the
ground up now I also love sports so I
ran touch football sessions in the
morning at at lunch times there's so
much scope to pursue things that
interest you then there's mastery
there are few things as enjoyable as
picking up a new skill there's that
fist-pumping moment of satisfaction when
you get to the point in learning and you
can say yourself I can do this and this
is really hard and I thought it would be
impossible for me to do but I'm really
good at it now and this is awesome
that's what mastery is about and
teaching maths provides endless scope
for developing and achieving it
now I remember one of the first times I
taught a class and was explaining the
existence of imaginary and complex
numbers when suddenly the eyes of every
student in the room just lit up because
they just encountered a totally foreign
idea but now they understood what it was
all about it really clicked for them and
then I knew I'd mastered it the ability
to take an idea absorb it and then
convey it clearly and succinctly from my
mind to theirs and it was exhilarating
and that happens to me every day I keep
working on different aspects of my
teaching and I keep improving mastery
it's so rewarding now teaching maths
provides lots of scope for autonomy and
mastery but it's real ace in the hole is
purpose the desire we had to make a
contribution and be involved in
something bigger than ourselves you see
it comes back to that year 10 class who
told me how so many people dislike maths
why do they just like maths now I think
one of the main reasons is because they
haven't been taught maths well they're
having been taught maths clearly and
simply they haven't been taught how
beautiful and surprising and fun it can
be they haven't been taught to
appreciate the power and elegance of
mathematics which the mathematician and
physicist Galileo called the language in
which the entire universe is written and
that's why we need people who are
passionate about learning and effective
about communicating to take up the
mantle of maths education it's such a
worthwhile cause it's a such a
worthwhile purpose to illustrate it's an
almost universal human experience to
enjoy and value music but imagine if you
travel to another planet where its
inhabitants hated music they hate it
because all they knew of it was
repetitive training exercises and
hundreds of hours of memorizing theory
about scales and time signatures and
musical notation would you not feel
compelled to break out an instrument and
play a song for them
to help them see that musics an
incredible avenue for expression and
creativity that's written into our very
bones yet you live on that plan already
on this planet the melodies and
harmonies of mathematics are seldom
heard and the purpose of a maths teacher
is to help people see and appreciate
mathematics for the symphony ideas and
even help people add their own voices to
the mix I still remember teaching a girl
in year 11 and 12 who joined the school
intent on dropping mathematics but I
knew she could do it and be fantastic at
it so I begged it ass day and not only
did she stay she became one of my very
best students when she graduated in high
school I got to celebrate her
achievement because we achieved it
together now that's a purpose worth
coming to work for so teaching
mathematics autonomy mastery and purpose
it's got tons of it it's really where
two consideration